for many people working from home now is
the new normal what is not normal is
what many businesses are going through
new data from Statistics Canada shows
about two-thirds of Canadian businesses
have been highly affected by lower
demand for their products and services
about half say it's so bad they've been
forced to cancel services they sell
those who survive are those who adapt
those who managed to turn lemons into
lemonade
tonight three companies share their
stories of finding new ways to do
business hi I'm Kerry silver the owner
of encore catering I've been in business
since 1979
we've catered over 40,000 meals in my
career to this point the bulk of our
business is being basically social and
corporate catering where we've done
product launches car launches weddings
bar mitzvahs christenings those types of
events I could see the writing on the
wall where events were starting to
cancel as early as March 2/10 people
were starting to cancel their events
fortunately I've got a couple of younger
sons that work with me and decided to do
a grocery home delivery prepared food
service which has taken off at the
beginning of March and it's feeding and
growing ever since they're preparing at
home they don't want to go into the
supermarket you need Tomatoes who's up
my name is Ryan silver and I'm the
director of encore catering we're here
for the community and the community has
really been there for us and that's the
most important part to take away from
this with contactless delivery coming
into the kitchen wearing a mask wiping
down boxes every piece that you know we
don't we don't let delivery people into
the building they have to drop it on the
loading dock we have to check it we
don't sign paperwork
hand sanitizer washing observe and you
get a lot of celery to
we do support a lot of frontline workers
through our donated meal program and we
hear the feedback and of what's actually
happening in the hospitals and it's
scary this isn't going away and maybe
it's going away for the short term but
it's not going away for the catering
business for a while and our business is
is change for six months to a year for
the foreseeable future so we need to
adapt we need a pivot and that's what
we've done it's tough to turn on a dime
but you have to it's survival of the
fittest and so you do what you have to
do and you just do it and we've done it
my name is Aziz Alam ko owner at good
neighbor it's a mini department store we
call it it's more than clothing we do or
footwear we do a lot of lifestyle
anything that relates to a young family
and their kids pre coalbed we were doing
incredible we're doing very well we were
very busy we took on a big expansion
plan for the store a second floor we
didn't know the severity of it until it
hit us and we right away figured out we
have this little website that we had pre
kovat it's a brick and mortar business
it was never gonna be an online business
but online has exposed us in a different
way now it's all organic to mean a
bidder all the government support that
we got thank God we were able to hold on
to some of our staff and they were they
were key in this thing they all rallied
around the business and they helped us
out to on personally to fill the store
the online store the doors are closed
but really were still open
I personally really engaged with these
people I know them all very well so I
decided to take on the whole delivery of
the local area myself I started knocking
the door leaving a box running out of
there with my mask on and it turned out
that everybody everybody started coming
out of the doors and saying hello to me
and that was that was amazing it's a
lifeline right now it's only it's a like
I said it's a drop in the bucket for
what it needs to happen the most
important thing that could have happened
is because it is keeping us in engaged
with our actual consumer who shops here
good morning guys my name is Shaggy -
Manny nickname is Shady childhood
nickname
we've been open Ferris 360 for 7 years
and we have 12 staff we do group fitness
we do personal training classes here a
little bit on the tougher side but we
look to cater to all levels we would see
anywhere between 350 450 people a week
you can imagine March it's a busy time
for gyms we're sort of live and things
are happening and all of a sudden
colvett hits we work with all the
protocols and then eventually shut
things down I thought you know we have
to still feel like we're part of the
community and have the community feel
like there's still a part of us
people want to rent out equipment so
that when basically in two days all of
our equipment when you come straight
from there we also included live classes
so zoom classes I sort of stepped up to
the plate after feeling really down but
you know something just clicked I had a
lot of good people around me
that motivated me 19:20 squat down
rotate just the other day we had a class
live I think there's most sixty-five
people so it was awesome we're in a
position now where you know there's the
community give back the rent relief you
know we couldn't be happier about that
it really puts us in a position to look
forward it's a whole new ballgame almost
every single week so more than that I'm
just looking for the health of sort of
everybody it's a it's a tough time for
people out there and you know you just
hope for the best for everybody and that
we come out of this team sooner than
later